[Music]
or send regards to y jaramillo with their
report of the day today, Tuesday, October 20,
early voting began this
past Saturday, but yesterday, Monday, was the
busiest day at the polls to
date in the county alone with
nearly 80,000 people  took advantage of their
right to vote and this figure includes
more than 29,500 people who cast their
ballots on Monday among the
busiest voting sites are northwest
of the centenary valley, as well as
the downtown samaranch
and las vegas ballpark sites have seen
long  rows
and the state unemployment department
says there is a new scam that
tries to take advantage of the sector of the
population without work some
applicants have reported
receiving emails that
appear to be alerts to the user of an
alleged failure in the data system
of the department of unemployment  unemployment
electronic notifications also
ask the recipient to respond
urgently and  check your
email very careful this is a scam
if you receive an email
from the leader do not respond and delete
it completely from your mailbox and
the hotel and investor company is
showing solidarity with other
sep properties to start reopening the
shows  from the tourist area of las vegas
according to the c
mpany's website in short it is already sched
led to reopen seven of its shows
in several of its prope
ties as of november 6 these
shows include tiger coppe
field where
frank fernández among other
shows will have
limited audience capacity and in some cases will be
moved to larger theaters in
order to maintain distance between
audiences and speaking of
grand openings in southern nevada
amd hoover dam reopens to the public today
reopening includes most
facilities such as the bridge and the
pedestrian walkway and as a
precautionary measure both the re  corridos or tours
of the visitor center as well as
the exhibitions will remain closed
to the public
for now now we move on with your
weather forecast temperatures will continue to be
in the 90s until
tomorrow get ready because
cooler temperatures are coming starting the
weekend have a good time  I am the day I
left Jaramillo and this was news now in
Spanish
[Music]